Okay, so let us say that this is our ROB here,
this is our Register Allocation Table and this is our set of Registers. And
let's suppose that our instructions are R1=R2+R3, R3=R5+R6,
R1=ROB1 x R7, it's ROB1 here because we're using R1 [UNKNOWN] this way.
And then R1 equals R4 plus R8 and then R2 equals
R9 plus ROB2, because it was really using R3 but it got renamed this way.
Let's say that all of these instructions have finished and
put these results in the ROB, and now it's time to commit them and
this is the next instruction that we'll be committing. At that point the RAT
entries are going to be. For R1, we need to point to ROB4. Why? Well because,
the entry in ROB4 is the latest write to R1 as far as the instructions that we
have issued, is concerned. So, you know, this was pointing to the register and
then when this one was renamed it made to point to ROB1.
And then when this one was renamed, we made that RAT entry point to ROB3 and
finally, it, it became ROB4 when this one was renamed and after that,
we didn't rename any R1 instructions. R2, the latest rename to it was ROB5 and
then for R3, the latest rename of it was ROB2. So, this is what we have in our
RAT for now. And let's assume that there are some values in the registers here,
they don't matter anymore because they will all be overwritten. So if you
remember before we had the ROB, when we were only doing [UNKNOWN] algorithm, and
were finishing instructions out of order, with no commit at the end. What was
happening is as the result is broadcast we need to see what's in the RAT for
that result. And if it says, for
example, that this was supposed to be produced by our instruction, meaning,
we were the latest rename of this then we would update the Register file.
If, for example, the R1 entry said that it shouldn't be asked that broadcast
gets the latest result, then we don't update the registers. With the ROB,
this changes because now, we have the commit. We will commit instructions.
In the correct order, in order of program execution. And each time,
we commit an instruction, we will deposits it's result in the register's,
no matter what the RAT really says about it. So when we commit ROB1 entry,
we're going to take this result of R2 plus R3, whatever that value is.
And we will put that value in the registers even though the renaming
in the RAT says that this is not the latest value for this register.
However we are then going to check whether we are the latest rename and
if we are not then we are not going to change the RAT. Basically the,
the RAT needs to indicate that the latest renamed value for R1 is still ROB4.
The fact that we committed ROB1 doesn't change that. So after doing this,
we free this ROB entry and it is now ready to take another instruction. Now,
we go to, try to commit ROB2. Well again, it needs to write a result in R3.
We take the result of the instruction and we do right it to the Registers.
Regardless of what the RAT says about it. But then, we look at the RAT entry for
R3, and check whether the RAT entry says that we are the latest rename for
this value. And in this case we are. So when we are committing this instruction,
if the RAT keeps pointing at the ROB2, it's going to be
pointing at an empty entry that will soon be used by some other instruction. So
what we need to do is change the RAT. To now point back to the Registers for
R3, so we made the RAT just point to the R3 value in the registers no longer, so
basically, now if any instruction wants to access R3, when it wants to
read operant, it actually needs to get this value, not a value from the ROB.
and after we have done this, we can commit this instruction fully,
which frees this ROB entry. And then we continue doing this, this instruction is
the next one that we will be committing, so what we do is we take this result,
we put it in R1, so we overwrite what was in R1 before,
we write whatever this value is, we then check whether for
R1 we are the latest rename and we are not. We are Rob3, this has Rob4,. So
we leave the RAT entry alone, and we can just free this entry from the ROB.
Now's a good time to kind of stop, and figure out, you know, why are we doing
this? Why are we depositing values in the Register that we know are going to be
overwritten soon? Well we are doing it because at any given point in time if we
need to stop there and take an exception like for example now if.
We want to take an exception, what will happen is, we can just drain the ROB,
just, just delete everything that is still in there, we can make the entire RAT
just point to the registers, meaning we will just change the center to point R1,
R2, R3, and the content that we already have now in the register file,
is exactly the content as of this point. So if we were not updating
the registers for every instruction, then we would not be able to do this.
The Registers would not be up to date at this point and we would not be able to
take an exception by just clearing everything from the RAT and
ROB. The fact that we did update it gives us the ability to do this.
Pretty much the Registers are always up to date. As of the commit point,
which means at any given time we can just stop at that point, cancel everything
from here, make this just point directly to the Register file. And
at that point, we are ready to fetch instructions from the exception handler.
Now, let's say that, that doesn't happen. What we can do then, is just let's
commit these instructions just to kind of illustrate once more what happens. So,
R1 equals R4 plus R8 is our next thing to commit. We write that to R1,
overwriting this value. We check whether we are the last rename for R1,
we are. So we make the RAT entry point directly to R1, basically from now on,
if somebody wants to. Read R1, they will end up reading this, not some ROB entry
and now we are ready to fully free this ROB entry and finally we can commit this
by again writing this result, checking whether we have the latest rename.
Yes we are. We point them directly to R1. And we finally free this ROB entry.
And, if we no longer have any instructions in the ROB, then we
have a state exactly as it should look when we have no instructions in the ROB.
Meaning the entire RAT is pointing directly to the registers.
The registers are all up to date, as of what was committed latest. And so on.
When your doing this, be mindful of the fact again that the values are copied to
Registers as we commit regardless of what the RAT says. But the RAT is updated
on commit only if we are actually changing the renaming from our ROB entry
to the registers. If the re-namings in the RAT is saying something else like
some other ROB entries still be pointed to here. Then we'll leave it alone
because the RAT needs to continue, to point to the latest value wherever that is